Andy Cohen reflects on the Orlando
shooting it just kills me and so
a late night host sat down with ETS
executive producer Brad Bessie on Monday
shortly after he attended a vigil at the
Stonewall Inn in New York City where he
honored those who lost their lives and
read several of their names out loud I'm
a gay American and I'm a gay New Yorker
and there was a vigil in my neighborhood
that I went to as a citizen I didn't
expect to take part in it I just wanted
to pay tribute to to those people the 48
year old got emotional talking about the
horrific massacre and the effect its had
on him this has touched me probably more
than anything just because I think I
could have been there and when I look at
the pictures of the victims I see their
faces and I see people that I know and
that I relate to and you go to a gay bar
and for some people it's the only safe
place that they have so the idea that
these people who were there to be just
with people that they loved and be safe
and have fun were you know killed being
who they are is just it just kills me I
think you know this was an attack on gay
people by a raging lunatic who hated
people like me it's a scary scary
reminder that there are really off of
people in the world Andy said the
tragedy has compelled him to take action
against gun violence nobody needs an
assault rifle except the people who are
actually protecting us it made me feel
like I'm gonna do what I can as a
citizen to get rid of assault weapons I
think we all have a responsibility to
raise our voices I am very proud to be
the only gay host on late-night
television and I don't classify my show
as a gay talk show I happen to begin
it's one of the things I happen to be
just as all those people
in Orlando that was one of the things
they happen to be they happen to be
killed for for being gay and that kills
me